I want to jump to this next story here
from the post Malone we got a lot of
post-millennial stories today FBI's
former top profiler warns of potential
for contagious copycat crimes in
Nashville after school shooting
following such a shooting O'Toole said
that communities should remain on alert
for up to two weeks due to the potential
for copycats quote in 2000 when the FBI
released its first report on School
shooters we found that the copycat
influence was powerful and it influenced
the 18 cases that we studied this report
was compiled in the wake of the
Columbine High School shooting which
claimed the lives of 13 people O'Toole
said that she believed the shooter's
Manifesto should not be released in that
case over fears of the contagion effect
now there's there that's a fair point oh
I agree but I also want to know what's
in the manifesto because if but they're
censoring it now right people can't see
oh we're conducting our investigation
but no offense trust me part of that is
they don't want you to know so they'll
say that just like when all the pictures
emerged you know over they was like oh
take him down when they said oh
identifies his you know he him and they
started taking him down one after the
next people were screen shooting them to
preserve it so the public could actually
see before they could shape-shift The
Narrative well here's the debate
if this Manifesto comes out and many of
these far leftists agree with it yeah it
could be this Manifesto could be a
direct call to incitement it probably is
direct call to violence so if it is and
I assume it is
should it be released the alternative Is
We I think we need to know what
motivated this so we can stop it from
happening again you're a thousand
percent correct I was literally just
gonna say that how can you stop and
prevent something from happening in the
future if you don't understand it and
identify it and study it I mean it's
just you know that's like Blissful
ignorance gonna end in a fatal
conclusion my concern with the manifesto
being released is that it would be
doctored and then sent out with a
political agenda I mean it no one
there's no way to trust a document that
we see now like I can't I don't want it
I don't want it look at the video
footage if you want to see why what she
was doing
uh and let's get her medical history now
she's no longer has her rights she
waived those rights to Medical privacy
after she killed all those people I I I
I I agree I think if if they're not
going to release the manifesto and
they're going to cite copycat fears I'm
fine with it I will then choose to uh uh
assume the motivations as and I think
it's fairly obvious so unless they want
to present any evidence to the contrary
this is clearly a far leftist gender
ideologue who killed Christians because
Christians are trying to stop the
mutilation of children hate crime yeah
well even then it won't matter because
it'll be called gender affirming care
and it won't matter because people the
average person who's uninitiated to
what's going on in the world right now
will see the Christians as aggressors in
a lot of these cases because they're
going to say you're trying to prevent
these kids like you really do have to be
steeped in not just the ideology but the
political ramifications of all this
together otherwise it really does
because of the how intricately the media
is able to weave these stories together
they will come out looking like the bad
guys and if they can't the media will
just stop reporting on it like they
always do if you if you let yourself
play identity here it'll get used
against you you need to focus on the
drug use of this kid this this 28 year
old woman right and how long she's been
on drugs has she been on since she was
14 that's the that's the focus
Pharmaceuticals is that proven here like
I haven't seen a quip about what
chemicals she was using okay I mean I
like I'm has like without knowing that
like I would have to know that for sure
if that was actually part of it if she's
trans there's a chance that she's on
testosterone okay so that she's actually
doing the chemical process yeah I mean
where's the new
who sponsors the the networks that are
reporting on that's another thing about
like medical you know safety and getting
information out there because if there's
people right now being really severely
manipulated okay into being like Oh who
am I am I binary am I this am I he she
my pronouns all this stuff it's like
mind-blowing to me how quickly this has
happened and you see a story like this
yeah no offense you're thinking twice
about all of this I've got to become
this person that person you hear all the
horror stories of people like regretting
that they're pushed into this whether
it's by abusive parents like the book
that you mentioned Tim
um genderqueer going through that
growing up in an abusive you know
environment and just questioning you
know your identity or it's bad to be a
woman or it's bad to be a man toxic
masculinity then no one wants to be a
man now I want to be a woman oh it's
terrible to be a woman now I want to be
a man I mean it's insane the back and
forth and back and forth if you see a
situation like this hope hopefully
people are going to say wait I want to
read about this I want to understand
maybe it gives you some reflection
personal reflection in your life about
the choices that you're making and how
you're being duped and totally
brainwashed by this you know by the
media and by these groups that actually
are trying to literally identify what
you might be despite what you're born
you know at Birth and teaching people in
hospitals to identify well this person
may be binary this baby that's like
three minutes old or it may be a a man
instead or a boy instead of a girl like
how is this even happening this is what
they're educating people about yeah I
want to give you a little Life Society
is going to tell you what they think you
are you get to tell Society what you are
real quick the the hill in the New York
Times and many others are reporting the
shooter was under doctor's care for an
emotional disorder but they did not
disclose the specific treatment okay so
I don't know what's the legal what's the
like the legality of if a murderer waves
do they waive their rights even a dead
murder do they have rights yeah I mean
like yeah what is their uh right to
privacy now now that they've committed a
heinous horrific crime by the way not
open to speculation caught on video not
like this isn't a whodunit we know who
did it the person died at the scene
officers responded now we're getting
this information the public has a right
to know there should be transparency
here for the purpose of public education
to know what transpired here because
otherwise it will continue to lie and
tell us it's this this this this this
and try to you know modify shape-shift
the whole narrative so that it's
something that suits their ultimate
ideological you know pathway and end
game and that's why I have a problem
with it I want to know the facts I want
to know the facts I wonder the facts I
want to know what's actually in the
manifesto I understand I guess I have a
great concern about you know Public
Safety or copycats and encouraging this
and you know a lot of colleagues you
know at Fox that say and one of my great
colleagues a great friend of mine Greg
Garfield says if you continue to report
and do this it makes highlights for
copycats and it encourages people to go
out there and and repeat these crimes if
we're giving it energy if we're giving
it life and breathing into it all the
time but there has to be a balance
between responsible reporting to not
encourage it and create copycats and
also allowing the public to have a right
to know the facts Etc because rightfully
so we have been come distrustful of the
corporate media and the narrative that
they push on us every single day which
by the way they have proved to not be
trustworthy when we find out time and
time again that what they told us was
bold-faced lives and that's what I want
to stop in this country because this is
America we should be able to know it's
not North Korea or China or Russia is
there a precedent for a murder a dead
murderer like their their privacy being
like okay now that this person's
committed the crime they're dead we're
gonna autopsy then we're going to find
out all their medical records is there
is there yeah well put it this way say
for example this was a case where the
perpetrator was not you know DOA done in
arrival killed on scene you need an
officer interaction blah blah blah then
you would say this is an ongoing
investigation and because of that we
cannot release this information because
it would jeopardize the
um you know the the nature of our
investigation uh the legitimacy of it
and our ability to be able to catch the
ultimate perpetrator and bring them to
justice you don't have that here
and to your point that's what you're
saying you have someone who we actually
know who committed it and now we
actually need to know why how how this
transpired who else knew there was an
issue what kind of you know culpable
responsibility there is in order to
actually make sure this doesn't happen
again otherwise you're going to see the
same thing it's going to be you know
Parkland it's going to be Uvalde it's
going to be well it's going to be all
these things over and over again without
having an understanding that leads
towards prevention and protection of
Public Safety who would we petition to
get these medical records
it's on the case I love it uh well you
know I'll tell you what how about the
power of subpoena that Congress has
you've seen this right now you see it
with uh Jim Jordan and the rest of them
in Congress that are calling for
transparency they have the power of
subpoena to be able to bring people
forward whether it's the D.A Alvin Bragg
to understand what he's doing with the
weaponization politicization of the
office or whether it's the Twitter files
and all the different investigations
they have going on they're saying we
actually want the information we want
the information they could call for that
here as well and say we want to make
sure we're going to subpoena we want to
know exactly what the hell happened here
and we want to know what's in the
manifesto we want to know what you guys
are hiding from us and we the people and
who we represent have a right to know
with the power of subpoena you will be
forced to comply with it no one is above
the law whether you're a D.A you're a
judge you're the lead officer
investigating this Etc you could
subpoena the doctor that was on that she
was you could try why not and let's see
absolutely protections but you should
and you should say uh what's going on
here now of course the doctor's going to
be afraid about personal liability Etc
did they know something was a crime
confessed to them or
um the intention to commit a crime the
intention to commit you know homicide
and Jewish school shooting or do a mass
shooting like this and we do know that
one friend was dm'd about this and there
was a suggestion that she wanted to
commit suicide life was not worth living
that she was going to do something
really bad Etc then everyone says okay
well is that person should they be
liable for failing to report and there's
all kinds of protections that go
involved with that whether it's turning
collaboration whether it's doctor
patient privilege but when the person
who perpetuated the crime and
perpetrated it
commits it is killed then how is it that
we have a responsibility to someone who
is it's not like an open question of
what they're guilty or innocent yeah he
did it I would be okay with offering
immunity to the doctor and even
anonymity I'm not interested in hurting
that person even if they said to the
person do it even if they were inciting
it I don't care at this point I want to
know the chemicals yeah and what what
created what was sort of the the
cocktail behind this about history of
you know mental illness a history of
what self-mutilation
um you know a history of like gender
dysphoria
um you know you know narcotics like who
knows but we do we do deserve to know we
should know otherwise what are you going
to do operate in a vacuum going forward
I don't know I think it's very dangerous
I'm getting fed up with the life I think
it's irresponsible yeah these shootings
are getting out of control I mean
obviously they're not a controlled
situation when they happen but it before
1999 I didn't know about school they
didn't exist in my mind they weren't
part of the natural discourse right to
see more than one a year that's just too
much for me if you don't find out the
information then they look for
scapegoats thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time